but first up you know this guy the
oscar-winning director of Bowling for
Columbine sicka when Fahrenheit 9-1-1
his latest documentary Fahrenheit 11/9
opens today the people's comedian
Michael Moore
that's what you are to me you are the
people's comedian Wow on the North
Korean way I mean Tribune of the people
and you have done it again maestro I
don't know how you keep doing it you
know you you do what journalism should
do which is you make what's important
interesting yeah and compelling and you
can't take your eyes off it and this
movie first of all the title fell right
in your lap there didn't it yeah he was
appointed president right
2:29 in the morning on eleven nine it's
spooky 16 yeah so the movie coming out
right before the election obviously you
want that you don't make any bones but
you're a polemicist like I am we want
people to agree with our point of view
yes
what would ones vote and vote in vote is
that the main message it's the main
thing you want people to come away
knowing from this it's not a democracy
if you're sitting on the bench everybody
has to get off the bench everyone has to
participate it's not a spectator sport
right and and but what the movie shows
and tries to explain as to why sometimes
people say on the bench
and and I get into talking about this
about the Democratic Party and and it's
it's a it's a bit of a balancing act in
this film because it's you know it's
it's listed as Michael Moore's trump
film but nobody wants to go to the
theater and look at Trump for two hours
no so so I do a favor for the audience I
don't think you see in more than 20
minutes in the film but it is about the
trumpian time in which we live no I I
think and how we got here I think it's
great that I'm gonna do this to you go
after the Democrats I mean yeah that's
what friends do yeah they're honest with
their friends that is correct Howard's
don't
and you are very brave in this I mean
you say very unflattering things about
both Clinton and Obama and Hillary yes
which is which was hard because I love
President Obama we may not have a better
president in my lifetime so I I was for
Bernie but I was out there stumping for
Hillary in the general election trying
to get people out there but you seem to
keep harping on this idea I mean I came
away from it with that old Republican
talking point notion Oh crooked Hillary
she stole it from Bernie but she didn't
steal it from Bernie
I mean she got a lot more votes than
Bernie correct except we'll never know
really no because in the 22 states that
he won which is 3 less than half the
country have to say what caucus did but
well so yes been a caucus States this is
they've got to get rid of that system it
should just be a primary where everybody
votes and there's no super-delegates
whoever gets the most votes is the
person who had the convention becomes
the candidate the DNC a few weeks ago
they had a meeting and they said they
got rid of the super-delegates but they
didn't people need to understand this
all they did was say the super-delegates
cannot vote on the first ballot at the
convention after that they can vote on
every ballot and everything else so they
did not get rid of the super-delegates
and and to the Republicans credit they
actually don't have super-delegates
whoever's at that convention is you know
whoever is there to represent the white
people that voted for
the white people deserve a party bill
they're Americans too that's how Trump
won he made he made his people feel like
a minority right right they still think
that I mean they think reverse racism is
a bigger problem than racism I mean
right the problem here though is that
and and I know this personally I feel
this first thing that's why it's in this
film because I Hilary lost Michigan by
about two votes per precinct yet all
right they never should have lost a blue
state and I interviewed John Podesta in
the filming so how did this happen and
and and how first of all the vote got
depressed because the people of Flint
when they were told that she got the
questions in advance and Bernie didn't
that they felt used as props out there
in the audience standing up and asking
the question and they already knew
Hillary already knew what the question
was
so people first were upset about that in
Michigan this never happens there were
more people a record number of people
voting in the April primary between her
and Bernie then who showed up in the
general election in November and in the
film I show something that sadly
President Obama did by coming to Flint
and and telling people the water was ok
it was still poisoned and then he
pretended to drink from a glass of water
and and then said it wasn't a stunt and
it was and it put us it just put a knife
in the heart of so many people in Flint
who were hoping he would come bring the
Army Corps of Engineers dig up these
poison pipes and replace the pipes in
the city and and in fact he didn't do
that and and then people gave up and a
lot of people stay at home they evolve
for trouble but they just they stayed
home and now you and I wish that that
wouldn't happen and you shouldn't stay
home and you should see clearly how bad
it's gonna be but you cannot talk to
people who have suffered so much
especially in this town where their jobs
were eliminated 30 years ago then the
economy was was ruined but pipes are
poised and then as I show in the film
Obama sends the Pentagon in to use Flint
as target practice and for 10 days and
10 nights in a row fires missiles and
bombs into abandoned buildings troops
firing their guns no
was told in advance that they were
coming everybody thought it was a
terrorist incident and and and it's like
they the feeling of we're just we're
nobody
and and America's forgotten us we're
still drinking out of bottled water and
and in this small little example you see
how sometimes the Democrats really screw
it up they're the party of the people
they should be there for the people they
should fight for the people and but the
good news about this election in
November is that people like myself and
others you've contributed to the Dias
Toffoli
I'm still filler but where do you get
where do you get this money because I
know divorces no alimonies
people ask me this all the time no
divorces no alimonies no kids right
no stupid hobbies like celebrities have
it own collect [ __ ] cars or
motorcycles paintings I don't do coke or
hooker you know no the crazy [ __ ] that
people do I don't do so a lotta and the
meds
so there's a lot of money that yeah and
that but that's what I spend it on right
right that's what because thank you for
doing that and what are the others have
done have gone out and by the way that
million looked silly or five weeks ago
when I did it because they said it
didn't look like it's in play it is in
play what it is very much in glass and I
said to you we can win the Senate and
you let me on the show even then oh wait
a minute where you gonna get this and I
said well you border two states right
here with Arizona and Nevada rights
those are winnable states for the Senate
you always write me no no no no but but
thank you for not asking you to
contribute well you got divorce what you
did
okay and you've been through a lot I was
gonna ask you you know through a watt
bill yeah this but there's never
anything worse than divorce I know every
guy tells me the same thing it's no no
there was the person who built the
fertilizer bomb I wanted to ask that guy
was worse than want to ask you that be
because you know I think getting lost in
the story about professor Ford is that
she had to move out of her house and she
gets death threats and there's a smear
campaign on the internet and things go
viral and you know we've become this
death threat Society yeah and you know
people say to me sometimes oh you know
do you think this could get get violent
I think it is violent but I also think
that's trumps next card to play yes I've
already seen him talking about if he the
Democrats take over he says they're very
violent people mm-hmm were the violent
people right he was right turns it
you're the puppet right turns it around
but that's what he has when the Muller
report comes out or when some other
thing crashes gonna he's the violent
person he he's the sexual predator Oh
totally is an admitted you're the only
person on TV who will state exactly what
you know if you if anybody is a public
house teacher in here a public school
teacher if there's a law in the state of
California and in most states that if
let's say your thirteen-year-old girl
student comes to you and says my dad
keeps saying that if I weren't
if I weren't his daughter he'd be dating
me my dad my dad said the other day that
the thing that we have most in common is
sex my my my here's yes this picture my
dad wanted me to take with me sitting on
his lap and kissing him if you were a
teacher and we're given that you were
required by the law to turn him in that
you've shown this on your show he has
done he did this when she was a tween
when she was a teen and he bragged about
how voluptuous my daughter is and
teenager that the thing is that we let
him get away with this the media let him
get away with it all his friends in the
media les Moonves Roger
Ales all the Bill O'Reilly the Matt
Lauer's I show this all in the film bill
shine the Lucknow yes exactly was the
guy at FoxNews right when Roger Ailes
was their cover had bill OH bill
o'reilly now he's the adviser to Trump
in the White House
prepping Brett Kavanaugh that Republican
they're always six degrees from sexual
harassment that point yeah yeah it's a
lot closer than just six degrees okay
they they believe in this that's why
they don't like this woman who's coming
forward and and they want to go after
her now and they've given her till
tonight or something right that
ridiculous
well right now I think when where cuz
women love ultimatums that's what yeah
especially shuttles who have been
victimized as men you know nothing like
saying to a potential rectum or what you
know you got till 10 o'clock its resting
when it's to tell us about the rape
you know it's like chuck grassley who's
85,000 years old and looks like he's out
of the crucible you know right you have
to okay I gotta go I could talk to you
all night I'll talk to you after Michael
Moore ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]